(machine clicking)
- We made it to New York City.
(light music)
Every time I'm in this city,
I find myself asking the same question.
Why is this place so giant?
Why does NYC feel like the
epicenter of the world?
(light music)
- This city, are you kidding?
- Back in the 70s, The New
Yorker magazine made this map,
showing how New Yorkers see the country.
I grew up in rural Oregon
and so this map sort of resonated with me.
I felt like New York had
this outsized presence
in our country, that everyone thought that
the United States was New York,
like it had some sort of
huge poll on everyone's mind.
And when I say huge, I don't mean
the eight and a half million people
that are packed into this city.
I also mean the outsized
cultural gravity of this city.
♪ New York, New York ♪
- It seems like every other
movie I watch, or book I read
is somehow connected to New York City.
So as we biked around this
city and had socially distanced
hangouts with our friends, and as we ate
the delicious things
this city has to offer,
I started to go down this rabbit hole
of how this city came to be
and how it became so damn big.
- [Man] This is New York,
the world's largest city.
- So I've boiled it down to three reasons,
the three reasons why New York
City is so big and important.
Number one, water.
(moderate music)
Let's look at a map real quick because,
you know, I like to look at maps.
The growth of New York
City is primarily a story
of perfect access to water.
Look at where it is compared
to the Atlantic Ocean.
It's not right on the ocean,
like it's not a beach,
you've got this nice long
island called Long Island
protecting it from the
elements and from invaders.
Zoom in and you see that
Staten Island is also here
to protect this city
from the wrath of the sea
or from conquers, and yet Manhattan
is just this tiny skip away from the ocean
for any boat fairing person
who wants to come and go.
Plus, these waters are super
deep, creating nice deep ports
which don't freeze during the winter.
They allow for loads of traffic
from bigger and bigger boats.
The first Europeans to
arrive and settle this land
were the Dutch, who were no strangers
to the economic advantages
of controlling water.
In fact, I made a whole video about how
the Dutch are obsessed
with controlling water.
So anyway, the Dutch arrive and they see
this prime piece of land and they're like,
"Yep, this is a sweet piece of land.
"We need this piece of land, let's name it
"after our favorite city back home
"that also has amazing access to water."
And New Amsterdam was born.
(moderate music)
The Dutch taking over this piece of land
is really the beginning of the
modern history of New York.
And I wanna tell you that story
but first, I wanna tell you
about today's sponsor,
which is Morning Brew.
It is a daily newsletter
that you get in your email.
It's free Monday through Saturday
and it is a fantastic way
to get informed about
today's business news.
I tend to wake up in the morning
and sort of just roll over
and grab my phone and just take
the path of least resistance
usually that's like opening up Instagram
and just sort of
scrolling to start my day.
It's not really the best way
to feel good about your morning.
What Morning Brew is, is a
better way to start your day.
Morning Brew is a digest
of the most relevant
and interesting news in
business, finance and tech.
Morning Brew does not focus on politics.
It's accessible, it's like
someone like me who's not
like a business insider or
a finance guy can read this
and feel like I'm more informed
about what's happening in the economy
and what's happening in big business deals
and sports and things that
I don't follow super closely
but feel like I have access to
through this really concise newsletter.
So, I'm a big fan of what they're doing.
It is free, it happens every
day, Monday through Saturday.
There's a link in my description
where you can sign up.
Thank you Morning Brew for
supporting this channel
and let's get on with the story.
What are the Dutch up to
on the island of Manhattan.
(light music)
As always, there were
people living on this land
who were not really familiar with
the concept of owning plots of land,
which clearly belonged to the earth dah!
And so the Dutch arrive and they're like,
"Oh, so you don't mind if
we buy this land from you
"and exploit it to get super rich?"
And so the Dutch paid the natives $24
and now the Dutch begin to
control this little plot of land
that is so perfectly connected to
and protected from the water.
(light music)
They kept the original name
that the Algonquian people
had given this island
which was Manna-hata.
And then they named
their surrounding areas
after Dutch names like Brooklyn and Bronx.
The British eventually took
over this piece of land from
the Dutch and renamed it
after one of their own cities,
that had nothing to do with water,
and after a few years
of settling this land,
the British really started
leveling up when it came
to controlling the water.
They started navigating up
this river called the Hudson River.
(moderate music)
So that they could connect
with the newly constructed
Erie Canal, which went all
the way to The Great Lakes.
(moderate music)
And so now you have this one city
that has protected access
to the Atlantic Ocean
as well as to the Great
Lakes all through water.
Okay, so perfect access
to water is number one
and the main reason why New
York City became so huge.
Number two is that New York
became the world's factory.
(light music)
So it's the 1800s, and
there are three industries
that are really taking over the world.
Number one is the mass
production of clothing.
Number two is the publishing of books
since there's all this
sciency stuff going on
and people wanna write
it down and publish it,
share it and everyone
wants to get really smart.
And number three was
the refining of sugar,
which European powers were stealing
from all over the world to
feed the growing obsession
with sugar back home.
These three have something in common,
they require some raw material
to be shipped in somewhere
to be transformed or refined or rearranged
and then shipped out as a final product
to customers all over the world.
To us in the 21st century
this seems super obvious
that our products would
travel around the world
to be transformed and manufactured
before they end up with us.
But back in the 1800s, a global
interconnected supply chain
was sort of a newish
thing, and New York City
was uniquely placed to take
advantage of this new process.
To add to this momentum back in Britain,
they were kinda pissed
off that their settlers
had declared independence from them,
and then had beat them in a war.
So as a matter of pride,
they sort of refused to trade
with any of the major revolutionary cities
like Philadelphia or Boston.
So this meant that New
York City was the place
to do global business, and the
city exploded with industry.
(light music)
This boom in factories
and industrial production
is really what built this
city, from the actual buildings
and infrastructure, to the population,
as workers flocked to the city for jobs.
Which gets me to my next point.
The third and potentially
most important element
that built the New York City
that we know today, is immigration.
As this city became the
industrial hub for making stuff
for people around the world, a steady flow
of immigrants started
flowing into New York City,
mainly from Europe at first.
Some of them were fleeing war
or oppression, starvation,
and some were just looking for a new life,
to take a risk, to try something new.
And New York was there to meet them.
So millions of immigrants started to flow
into New York City, many getting on ships
and arriving on this island.
By 1860, almost 70% of adults in New York
were foreign born, 70%.
(upbeat music)
These immigrants didn't just fill the jobs
of the industrial and commercial
growth of New York City.
This influx of immigrants from
so many different backgrounds
began to lay the foundation
of the incredibly diverse
multicultural experience
that is New York City today.
(upbeat music)
But even though they all came
from different backgrounds,
they also had one thing in common.
Immigrants tend to be a self
selecting group of risk takers.
After all, they made
the long arduous journey
into the unknown to start a new life.
In other words, they're
natural entrepreneurs.
Look what we found.
Best tacos on the East Coast.
Coz they just like Tijuana, here we go.
(murmurs)
- Now let's go to that park.
- [Woman] Num-num?
- Yeah.
- So you take a bunch
of risk takers and you gather them
into one large growing
city to build a new life,
and that creates a culture of its own,
a culture of new ideas, new
businesses, new inventions.
And when you have a
bunch of new businesses
and new inventions and new ideas,
you often have rich people show up
to try to bet on those ideas
to see whose idea will actually
win, with the intention
of making money on a
successful idea or invention.
I'm using a bunch of words to describe
the process of investing or finance.
For many years in the
United States, the epicenter
for banks and lenders was Philadelphia.
But as New York City filled up
with entrepreneurial
immigrants, the epicenter
of investing slowly
shifted to the place where
the best bets were happening.
And New York City became
the financial epicenter.
All of the industrial
production and factories
eventually went away, but the
banks and the stock exchange
that were built on its shoulders stayed
and became the economic
foundation of modern day New York.
(moderate music)
This explanation of New York
City helps me understand
the more elusive mystique
about this place.
And that it's poll isn't just about
the eight and a half million
people that live here,
but that those many people, their stories,
where they came from, the
lives they built here,
all from different backgrounds,
and yet they were all engaged
in the same experiment,
cramming into this city to build something
that had never been built before.
- [Presenter 1] New York City
is as amazing in its own way
as the Grand Canyon.
- [Presenter 2] New York City.
- [Presenter 3] New York City.
- [Presenter 4] New York City.
- So there you have it,
New York City is a place
that had a perfect
connection to the water,
that was perfectly placed
to be the world's factory,
as the global economy started to blossom.
All of this attracting
risk taking immigrants,
who built the population
but also planted the seeds
for the uniquely New York
character that we know today.
(upbeat music)